Dreamworks' all-singing, all-dancing trolls
are back in a holiday special, which finds
Poppy, Branch, and friends on a mission to
create a new day of celebration for the Bergens.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm going to reveal some cool details
and easter eggs you may have missed in the
Trolls Holiday special.
And I'm running a Trolls book giveaway on
this video.
To enter, make sure you're a subscriber and
leave a comment below about the Trolls movie
or special.
When the Cater-bus falls into a wormhole,
there's a lovely easter egg to the original
Troll toys that these animated characters
are based on.
Biggie, Branch, and Poppy all turn into little
plastic trolls, like the troll toys that were
so popular in the 1960s and again in the 1980s
& 90s.
And Guy Diamond turns into a little plastic
troll covered in glitter, which is funny because
the character of Guy Diamond, who's naked
except for glitter, was created as a tribute
to the original troll dolls which often didn't
wear any clothes.
As for Cooper, he turns into a giraffe troll
toy just like the original set of animal trolls
that were the inspiration for the design of
his character in the movie!
Later in the special, there's another shout-out
to the original troll toys when Poppy and
Branch sing a song suggesting a whole range
of holidays the Bergens might like to celebrate.
Among those holidays is Good Luck Troll Day
which involves putting a gem in your belly
button.
This is a little tribute to Thomas Dam, the
Danish creator of the original troll dolls,
who named his toys Good Luck Trolls, and it's
also a hat-tip to the 1990s toys called Treasure
Trolls which had a little jewel in their tummy
button which you could make a wish on.
When the Caterbus crash-lands in front of
King Gristle's castle, the next thing we see
is loads of butterflies fluttering away.
And those butterflies are the same colours
as the Caterpillar that took Poppy and her
friends to Bergentown, which is a nice touch
because, in real life, caterpillars do transform
into butterflies.
And, in case you missed that, another Caterpillar
explodes into butterflies during the Troll-A-Bration.
By the way, something similar happened in
the first Trolls movie when the DJ Stage Bug
burst into a mass of butterflies while Poppy
was giving out invitations to the Trolls party.
There's lots of cool little details on the
Caterbus Express.
For example, if you look at Cloud Guy, you'll
notice he's wearing a blue driver cap which
has a cloud on it that's the same shape as
he is.
And the controls on the bus's dashboard are
similar to the bug defibrillators that Branch
used to bring Poppy back to life after she
was attacked by spiders in the first movie.
The Holiday special also has a few little
reminders from the Trolls movie of King Gristle's
first date with Bridget, aka Lady Glitter
Sparkles.
First of all, there's a pepperoni pizza lying
around the throne room.
And, like their first date, which they spent
at Captain Starkfunkles Roller Rink, they
also end up skating in Trolls Holiday, though
this time, as it's winter, they go ice rather
than roller-skating.
Unlike the Troll Tree in the movie, if you
look closely at the Troll Tree in the Holiday
Special, you can see that it's shaped like
a classic troll's hair, just like in Poppy's
Holiday presentation to Bridget and Gristle.
And speaking of hair, the top of Bridget's
throne in the Bergen castle has a similar
shape to the hairstyle she had as Lady Glitter
Sparkles.
To sell their various holiday ideas to Bridget
and Gristle, Poppy and Branch dress up in
crazy costumes and perform a song-and-dance
routine.
This sequence is a hat-tip to Branch's voice
actor Justin Timberlake and his many Saturday
Night Live skits playing a guy who sells everything
from vegan food to wrapping paper while singing
and dancing in crazy outfits.
There was actually also a nod to Timberlake's
SNL sketches in the Trolls feature film when
Poppy did a song and dance dressed up in a
basket costume, wearing white gloves.
The only time Biggie's pet worm, Mr Dinkles,
speaks in the feature film is when they discover
Creek is alive, and instead of reacting with
his usual squeaky-voiced 'mew' sound, he says,
'Oh, snap', in a deep voice.
In that movie, Mr Dinkles was voiced by the
film's director Walt Dohrn, who also voices
Cloud Guy, but because Mr Dinkles has a bigger
role in the Holiday special, he's now voiced
by prolific voice actor Kevin Michael Richardson.
By the way, in the final scene the words 'Happy
holidays to all, and to all, a good night'
are a spin on the last line of the popular
poem, 'A Visit from St Nicholas', which is
also known by its famous first line, 'Twas
the night before Christmas.'
Now, what did you enjoy most about the Trolls
Holiday?
And were there any other cool details you
spotted?
Let me know in the comments below and don't
forget to also subscribe for your chance to
win an awesome Trolls book.
I'll announce the winner on an upcoming video,
so if you enjoyed this, make sure you turn
on your notifications and hit that like button.
And while you're here, why not tap the screen
now to watch more of my Trolls and other animation
videos?
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!